tout cas positifs de couronnes à virus
sera désormais considérée dans ce
département comme suspect de variants
jusqu'à preuve du contraire c'est à dire
qu'il bénéficiera d'un contact racing
renforcer immédiat d'une mise à l'abri
accompagné immédiate d'une durée
d'isolement porté à dix jours contre 7
jours un test pcr spcr sera réalisée
avant la levée de l'isolément et un test
pcr sera réalisée dès le premier jour
chez tous les cas contacts éventuels la
moselle bénéficiera pour cela de l'aide
et de l'appui des équipes du ministère
et des autres agences régionales de
santé que je remercie pour leur
mobilisation solidaire